this is where she spends most of her
time here in the kitchen
vassilisa crevo show Kivar has been
unemployed for two years
jobs are few and far between Western
sanctions and low oil prices have hit
the Russian economy hard sometimes I'm
paid in food instead of money that means
I do a little something for someone and
they give me a tasty lunch or some
groceries in return whatever they no
longer need food sharing is the latest
trend to hit Russian cities and although
people don't tend to offer vassilisa
three-star meal neither she nor her sick
mother has to go hungry I don't find it
disgusting at all quite the opposite I
think it's great and I really like the
fact that you don't throw away food but
instead you give it a second life the
youth that are easy and that's exactly
the sentiment behind food sharing the
movement attracts not only those in need
but also people like Jaeger Medina cough
he makes tofu for a living and is more
than happy to give away the byproduct or
Cara
Rossler give me product it's immoral to
throw away products that can be used in
addition yog or makes daily deliveries
of okra to a small grocery store on the
edge of Moscow the shop stocks products
mainly aimed at it's vegan customers but
recently more and more needy people have
come here hoping to get hold of some
okra the soy by-product is rich in
protein and other nutrients and most
importantly it's free a fact that has
spread very quickly prevent is a waste
of food this is actually the main target
of food sharing throwing of eatable food
away is a serious problem with dramatic
consequences but here in Russia food
sharing has got primarily and not the
social function in times of needs in the
evening vassilissa travels to a Moscow
suburb to meet a young woman she's got
to know over the Internet
the woman brings her a bag of potatoes
and the problem of tonight's evening
meal is solved I'm thrilled to get these
three kilos of potatoes and I'm grateful
tomorrow vassilissa may go and hunt down
the grocery store that Jaeger makes his
donations to food sharing she says is
helping her survive these times of
economic crisis